New York state lawmakers have voted to
ban chokeholds of the type that killed
Eric garner part of a package of police
reforms under consideration but police
tactics may only be part of the problem
we spoke to black officers all around
the country about the challenges that
they face era Barnett is in York City's
Times Square for us arrow good morning
what do these officers tell you good
morning Tony you know it was really
interesting they really opened up about
the complicated feelings black cops must
contend with one of them in fact from
the NYPD said she was called anti cop by
a white colleague for suggesting that
the officers who failed to intervene and
George Floyd's death should be held
accountable and that is just one example
of the emotional tightrope officers of
color must overcome what does it feel to
be an officer of color at a moment like
this it's complex
lieutenant Grecia herdsman has been with
the NYPD for nearly 28 years the
protests yesterday people stood in front
of me and they're like you know how do
you feel you know being black and
knowing what's happening do you believe
in protest and I was like yes I believe
it's your right to protest peacefully my
son is probably here right now
law enforcement officials like
lieutenant herdsman are trying to find a
balance between their duty to their jobs
and their identity as black Americans
Fayetteville North Carolina police chief
Geena V Hawkins I was excited to be able
to say I want to be a part of the
protests I want to walk with the
community and then we had the violence
come up I had to do my job which is
protect the community
sergeant Jamie Jones is with the Decatur
Police Department in Alabama Decatur has
roughly 130 people on its police force
19 of them are black I think that if you
don't study ones culture or know someone
else's background that you're dealing
with and you can see them as a threat
when they're not even a threat and do
you think that happens yeah I believe
that does happen you know there have
been times when I've been out of uniform
where I have been treated differently
you know I keep those stories at home
or you know a way from work when you're
not in uniform in town are you ever
concerned for your safety out of uniform
I'm just another guy I'm a black man
first alright and if they've had any
issues with you know the black race or
what they see on TV then they may feel
threatened a little bit cry just just
the side of me or being in close
proximity me I think overall black
officers don't speak about what's
happening in the black community white
officers and I think it's an underlying
fear of what would it mean about my
relationships because the police in
relationship can be a close one when
you're on the streets you need each
other do you think that if you would
share with some of your white colleagues
those experiences you might open their
eyes to the fact that this does happen I
believe some of them will sympathize
with me and understand like I said it's
just it's just personal preference in
2016 a Pew study found 92% of white
officers believed the u.s. has made the
necessary changes to assure equal rights
for African Americans while only 29% of
their black colleagues agreed that same
study found 86% of officers felt high
profile fatal encounters between police
and black people made their jobs more
difficult
chief Hawkins acknowledges it's
challenging but says she's unwavering in
her position as a black member of law
enforcement profession who will we leave
it up to it's a hard position to be in
to know what I stand for and to know
what it should be like and to know what
is gonna take to eradicate the ones that
should not be in this uniform but I need
the good ones that stay strong I need
the good ones to speak up I need the
good ones to know we are going to change
the world with George Floyd
so yeah it's hard but it was never
promised to be easy sounds like what
you're saying is you think you can do
more from inside the police force
absolutely absolutely
now chief Hawkins also believes that the
main way to build trust is for police
agencies to to make it mandatory for
police agencies to report use of force
disciplinary action and other crime
statistics she says right now all of
that information is of voluntary and
even as New York State prepares to pass
a whole slate of police reforms they sat
idle for years facing resistance from
powerful police unions Anthony but that
was until nationwide protests changed
things
Errol thank you as she is chief Hawkins
said we need the good officers to speak
up